[Music]
starting off this hour is going to be
jeremy and saint paul hi jeremy welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call i was
listening to a christian talk radio guy
out of memphis area today and he was
talking about financial planner
i called up and said hey do you know
dave ramsey because he says this guy's
not following everything's gonna be all
right and he said well i know who he is
but i don't know if he knows bible
prophecy very good and i don't really
agree with what he's saying so i just
wanted to ask you give you a chance to
respond about what do you think about
bible prophecy because he believes
there's going to be a
someday christ has come there's going to
be a pre-millennial
or he's going to set up a thousand year
kingdom but before that there's going to
be a seven year tribulation most
believers i know
feel that we're getting close but every
time i listen heal you it's like it's
gonna go on like it always has so i just
wanted to ask you about that
okay well that's fair well obviously uh
those of us that are people of faith
that are christians um
and have studied the bible much know
that the study of end times is
eschatology right
and there are three
uh forms of thought around that pre-trib
post-mid-trib and post-trib
meaning tribulation uh and so when uh
you know
when are we gonna be called to heaven
before the tribulation in the middle of
the tribulation or after the tribulation
and depending on which one of those you
would fall into then you'd be much more
concerned about this if you're going to
be
called to heaven
instantaneously in the air prior to the
tribulation
then you would not care from a financial
planning perspective
correct
correct
yes you're the only person i know i
heard you talking so the only pers the
only people you would the only people
that would worry about it would or that
would be concerned about financial
planning during a tribulation would be
mid-tribbers or post-tribbers does that
make sense
absolutely i agree with you okay all
right cool so then once we say that then
we've got to say uh
you know how many times
since scripture was written
have uh intelligent well-meaning people
decided that they recognized the signs
from revelation and that now we're in
the end times
you want me to tell you how many times
every freaking year
every year
i mean in 1988 a guy wrote a book 88
reasons jesus is coming back in 88
missed that one
right
and you can go through every the
and
no man will know the time or the hour
jesus said from his own mouth
okay remember that
yes sir okay and so
yes there's some interesting very uh
mind-bending and spiritual questions
that can be asked around the end times
and the study of prophecy but i'm gonna
stop real short
of predicting the end times
based on the fact that a
bunches people smarter than me and that
guy who was questioning that on the
radio in memphis a bunch of people
smarter than either one of us have
missed it every single year for 2000
years
on when they thought he this was all
happening
i mean you i can show you some very
interesting studies during world war ii
that uh peop that real smart theologians
were convinced uh hitler was the
antichrist
and they had real good lineups on line
by line by line by line from revelations
all the evidence that this invasion and
this movement in the war and the
extermination of the jews and all of
that kind of stuff there was really good
evidence that that was the end times
oops missed it you are you are pre-trib
though right or
i don't think it matters for this
discussion yeah
no no the reason no my point is i'm
going to come to the same conclusion
about financial planning regardless of
whether i'm pre-med or post-trib
because in order to plan for the end
times in as a mid-tribber or
post-tribber you would have to believe
you can predict them
and i'm telling you very thoroughly here
that i don't believe that
i don't believe you can tell me
sometimes i'm thinking it's going to
happen every day but yeah
hey and and as screwed up and toxic as
this world is come quickly lord jesus
okay amen i'm ready baby let's let's
let's call this thing it's messed up
it's sodom and gomorrah out there man it
is a screwed up bunch of human beings
out there running around they're all
over the place you don't believe me just
open up a social media account there's
some bonkers people out there
and so from a from a faith perspective
yeah i i
but but can we not look back truthfully
as intelligent human beings and say
this has happened before
this has happened in rome this has
happened with the inquisitions this has
happened with the salem witch trials
this has happened you can go back and
find all kinds of times that you look
out into society and go side society has
gone to hell in a handbasket it must be
a sign of the coming of the age
and it's just
you just can't predict it i don't think
and uh and i know a lot of theologians
and a lot of good friends of mine that
think they've got it dialed in but man
i'm just telling you that's a that's
thin ice when you start thinking you're
gonna dial in the day and you you got
this figured out that
i mean there were people who thought
bill clinton was the antichrist i heard
a whole thing on that
and uh and he obviously wasn't
pretty obviously if he if he is he's a
really bad one
you know and so um
poor bill
but you know you got to start naming you
know
this invasion of this and this movement
of that and you have to and you align
all of that with the uh
with the with the innuendo and the hints
in revelation and it's a fun exercise to
try to do it but when you go down that
rabbit hole the thing you have to
remember is
you will be one of a bazillion people in
the last 2000 years that got this wrong
that when you start calling the end
times with certainty
so much certainty that you start
changing your financial plan and how
you're going to live your life
uh then you're about to be wrong you're
about to be wrong and so whether i
believe it's post-trib mid-trigger
doesn't matter what i believe that
overshadows all of that is that you
can't predict when the end times are and
people that say that they can are wrong
have been so far a hundred percent of
the time
they've got a hundred percent wrong
guessing game
so far now one of these days somebody's
going to guess it and get it right
but
i hadn't hadn't figured that one out yet
so not betting uh not betting my mutual
funds on that yeah so that that's where
that comes from and that's a great
discussion though jeremy thank you for
giving me the opportunity to do
something i don't get to do very often
that's fun